hello everyone and welcome
thank you all so much for coming tonight
my name is claudia fury and i'm the
chairman of the washburn college
republicans
we are very excited to be hosting this
event tonight and extremely thankful for
young america's foundation for helping
make this possible
i would like to say a special thank you
to the logan family for their generous
support in making tonight's event
possible
tonight we have the pleasure of hosting
michael knowles which has been an event
that has taken months of planning
countless emails and phone calls
one reason this event is so important to
me as well as many other students
sitting in the audience tonight
is because we believe in the freedom of
speech
and we will fight for the ability to
voice our opinion on every college
campus and we refuse to be silenced by
the administration our fellow students
who disagree with us
[Applause]
universities around the country present
a common theme of wanting everyone to
look different but think the same
they are wanting to tell you what to
think and not how to think
they are willing to sacrifice the truth
to save people from possibly being
offended
one of the goals we hold as college
republicans is to promote open and
respectful conversation on campus
i ask you all tonight to stay curious
and to have an open mind
with this being said whether you agree
or disagree with mr noel's viewpoints
tonight we expect everyone to remain
respectful and listen to what he has to
say
if there are any disruptions for members
of the audience we will gladly have
washburn police escort you out of the
auditorium
immediately following his remarks there
will be a q a so please reserve any
comments or questions for that time
with all that being said mr knowles is
the host of the michael knowles show
author of the book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
he graduated with a ba in history in
italian from yale university
and in 2017 he published a book titled
reasons to vote for democrats a
comprehensive guide
[Music]
this to 266 empty page book was deemed
by president donald trump
a great book for your reading enjoyment
every person in this room is fortunate
enough to live in the greatest country
in the world
that guarantees the freedom of speech
i'm honored tonight to be here
exercising that freedom of speech with
all of you
and with that it is my pleasure to
introduce to you mr michael knowles
[Applause]
right here
thank you so much
wow thank you
thank you very very much
really i really appreciate it i really
appreciate the invitation it's wonderful
to uh to be here
happy trans visibility day i think we
need to get that out i
i did not know that it was trans
visibility day when i accepted this
invitation to speak
i cannot say i have that particular
feast day on my calendar so
that was a uh
a happy coincidence to assuage
everyone's fears on visibility day
we see you
boy oh boy do we see you we always see
you
it would be impossible not to see you
it's a real pleasure to be at washburn
thank you to yath as always for hosting
thank you to the logan family for
sponsoring this lecture series i thank
you to claudia and the
college republicans for for all of their
work putting this together but most
importantly i would like to thank the
washburn president jerry farley
i would like to thank president farley
for personally signing the contract to
invite me here today
before he condemned me for spreading
hate and misinformation
i
sort of a strange way for a university
president to treat a guest that he
personally invited
you sign a contract you say thank you we
want you to come this day and then a
couple of weeks later you libel and
defame that speaker before he says
anything at all
as some sort of menace to society but
that is exactly what president farley
did in a campus-wide email just a couple
of days ago i have the text of the email
right here so in case anyone didn't get
it on this campus or elsewhere a
president farley wrote
to the washburn university community
a washburn student organization has
invited a speaker to campus who has a
history of inciting fear
and distrust
that's me
don't i strike fear into your heart
i'm i'm terrifying i'm a regular conan
the barbarian that's what i am
how can president farley sleep at night
knowing that such a behemoth as i stalks
about the world
he goes on well i am strongly in support
of first amendment rights here we go
whenever you get that preface you know
nothing good is going to follow
says i am disappointed when those rights
are used to make others feel unwelcome
and even unsafe in our community while
we support the right to speak freely
washburn university does not condone the
hate and misinformation
spread by the speaker and his supporters
you notice that president farley never
cites any examples of the hate and
misinformation that he is alluding to
because no such examples exist
it's a it's a lie
instead he just generally libels and
defames me without a shred of evidence
and why does he do that what have i said
that president farley considers to be so
dangerous
here it is he says
thursday happens to be international
trans visibility day
actually in president farley's typo
laden email he said that it's
international tans visibility day
well as a member of the sicilian
american community
i feel qualified to represent
tan's visibility day
but i i think he meant to say
transvisibility day and so that that's
where the hate and misinformation comes
from
it is because of my thesis tonight that
men and women are different
for all of human history everywhere in
the world until about five minutes ago
that observation was common sense and
completely uncontroversial
today that basic fact of human nature is
considered hateful
jerry farley the president of this
public university taxpayer-funded
university
considers the
difference between men and women to be
misinformation this is something parents
might want to take into consideration
when they're thinking about signing that
tuition check what sort of beliefs the
leadership of the university has
if the president of the university does
not believe that men and women are
different one wonders what is being
taught
in the classroom
president farley continues he says
washington washburn university supports
the trans community and students who
identify as lgbtq plus we support and
stand in solidarity with trans people
around the world and encourage you to
learn more about the issues affecting
students faculty and staff who identify
as lgbtq plus we will continue to engage
our resources to influence camp the
campus community
to be an inclusive place
where all feel they are protected
affirmed and valued
where everyone feels affirmed and valued
i don't i don't mean to complain
but president farley's email does not
make me feel particularly affirmed
or valued
more importantly
i suspect that email doesn't make the
students who put this event together
feel affirmed or valued i suspect the
vast majority of people on this campus
virtually everyone knows that men and
women are different i don't think that
email makes them feel affirmed or valued
president farley is condemning every
single student on this campus with a
modicum of common sense by his email and
so he concludes i encourage you to
celebrate the day with messages of
compassion and support with your help
this university can be a shining light
and example to the greater community
we will learn together and from each
other and we'll be better people for it
jerry farley president
i hope that we will learn together this
evening
i hope we will learn
or relearn basic facts about reality and
human nature
if that is too much for anyone for
president farley i hope at least we will
learn that conservatives will not be cow
towed into silence and submission to the
ridiculous ideological fantasies of the
radical left that we most certainly will
learn
this lecture has been misrepresented by
the very always irresponsible press
as anti-trans
this speech is not anti-trans it in no
way belittles or threatens or mocks
anyone for their sexual confusion
on the contrary
this speech is a lifeline this is a
support for people who have fallen into
a false and destructive ideology called
transgenderism
in recent years the number of people who
identify as transgender has exploded
as lgbt generally has exploded
historically about one to two percent of
people have identified as lgbt
10 years ago that number jumped 3.5
percent of americans at that time
identified as lgbt according to gallup
polling
last year that number rose to 5.6 that's
a 60 percent increase in just nine
years that increase has been driven
almost entirely by gen z the zoomers
20.8 percent of whom more than one in
five of whom now identify as lgbt
that is a statistical impossibility
either alex jones is right and they are
putting something in the water
that is turning the freaking zoomers gay
or
or i think more likely we're looking at
a phenomenon that is rooted not in
biology but in a kind of social mania
whatever is in the water i think the
surge has to do more with society i
spoke a few weeks ago with a woman by
the name of helena kirschner
helena is a 23 year old woman who began
to identify as a man in transition quote
unquote to be a man just a few days
after her 18th birthday transitioning
for those who don't know is the word
that transgender ideologues have given
to a medical malpractice in which people
who are suffering from sexual confusion
take cross-sex hormones and sometimes
even mutilate their healthy organs to
appear cosmetically more like the
opposite sex
helena had suffered from body image
issues since she was a teenager
like
every teenager like especially like most
teenage girls
usually people grow out of this and
become more comfortable in their skin
but but now radicals are affirming their
delusions and luring people into a very
pernicious ideology
helena began to isolate herself online
she didn't have a lot of friends she
would isolate herself on social media on
tumblr in particular and there her new
virtual friends encouraged her to be a
man
helena was vulnerable she was confused
she was a teenage girl and she thought
that by injecting herself with
testosterone she might be able to solve
her problems
a few days after her 18th birthday
helena walked into a planned parenthood
clinic of course a planned parenthood
had hard-earned the reputation as the
least regulated place for teenagers to
get cross-sex hormones so she walked in
the predators at planned parenthood gave
her a 20-minute questionnaire they then
immediately gave her the highest
allowable dosage of testosterone they
downplayed all the side effects and they
sent her on her not so merry way syringe
in hand
quickly helena began to suffer terrible
mood swings she had a massive increase
in her sex drive she had rage attacks
that were so intense that she began to
harm herself
she was institutionalized twice she saw
a slew of psychiatrists
and none not one of these mental health
professionals ever suggested that
perhaps
this major change that she had undergone
might have something to do with the fact
that she a young girl was injecting
herself with male hormones they never
brought it up they just prescribed her
new psych drugs to take on top of the
testosterone
by luck or by providence helena's fits
of rage became so intense that she would
sometimes neglect to take the
testosterone
then and only then wouldn't you know it
her symptoms began to abate
she realized that the reality
of a woman injecting herself with male
hormones was not matching up to the
fantasy that she had had of being a man
the fantasy could never match up to that
reality because no matter how many drugs
helena took no matter how many surgeries
she could have undergone she could never
be a man because she is a woman and
women cannot be men
helena learned the hard way that fantasy
is not the same as reality
fortunately she chose reality
fortunately also for her she does not
appear to have all that many permanent
effects from this process of
transitioning
the same cannot be said of everyone who
falls down the transgender rabbit hole
many of whom are left permanently
injured and filled with regret when
their delusions fail to alter reality
not every person who identifies as
transgender will experience immediate
regret some people that i've spoken to
some transitioners describe a period of
pleasure even euphoria
when they begin their transition process
some people will come to regret the
procedures only later after the initial
thrill wears off
and that will leave them as bad off as
they were to begin with if not worse off
some people may never experience
conscious regret
statistically speaking they're very
unlikely to be better off than they were
before the hormones and before the
mutilations statistically the rates of
anxiety and depression and suicide among
post-transitioners are basically the
same as pre-transitioners
but these people may never come to any
sort of conscious regret that's true
the problem with transgenderism the real
the central problem is not regret but
reality
transgenderism is simply not true
it is a false account of human nature
which holds that one's true self has
nothing to do with physical reality
according to transgenderism one can talk
like a man have an adam's apple like a
man walk like a man have all of the male
appendages all of the male chromosomes
and yet somehow still be a woman
transgender activists usually will not
explain how this is possible
because there is no explanation because
it's incoherent
one explanation that they sometimes
offer you may have heard this before is
that sex is not gender
they'll say sex and gender are different
now it's it's worth pointing out that
this explanation is not actually an
explanation
it's just a statement it's just a claim
without any evidence whatsoever
and then when the activists try to
defend this claim the idea becomes even
less coherent sometimes these activists
will differentiate sex and gender by
saying that sex is physical and gender
is socially constructed sex you see is
your body and gender is how you think
about your body okay
this distinction leads to an obvious
problem
if sex is physical
and gender is just a state of mind
well then if there's a conflict between
your sex and your gender
just change your mind
if gender is socially constructed
then gender can be socially
reconstructed can't it
surely it would be easier to reconstruct
this social construct than it would be
to reconstruct your body which can never
be successful
certainly that would be less expensive
certainly that would be less painful
at this point activists will usually
take back their claim that gender is not
physical they will say that gender is
not merely a state of mind but actually
a biological fact they will make dubious
claims about brain scans they will say
that in the minds of transgender people
who look like men and they've got all
the markings of men their brains
actually more closely resemble women
they will claim that gender identity
like biological sex is rooted in the
body in the brain in the hormones etc
but at this point the sex gender
distinction completely falls apart now
we are told both are physical
this is how we end up with such phrases
please pardon my use of this phrase as
the
biologically female penis have you heard
that phrase
that's a phrase that is going around in
academic circles it's a term coined by
an actor india moore who is a man who
thinks that he's a woman
and this of course results in a
contradiction
a person cannot simultaneously be a man
and a woman because to be a man means
not to be a woman to be a woman means
not to be a man
even in the vanishingly rare cases of
anatomical or chromosomal ambiguity
hermaphroditism intersexuality whatever
you want to call it
a person's biology even then is not
entirely ambiguous even in that
exceedingly rare case a person may still
be classified as a man or a woman in the
case of transgenderism there isn't any
ambiguity at all
in the case of transgenderism all of the
biological markers point to one sex and
then the person mistakenly believes that
he is the opposite sex
the only way even to possibly resolve
this conflict would be to say that sex
refers to your body
and gender refers to your soul
to say that sex is the physical part of
our being and gender is the metaphysical
part of our being
most transgender activists will refuse
to talk about it in these terms because
in in my experience most transgender
activists deny the existence of the soul
sounds a little old-timey sounds a
little bit too christian for all of
these enlightened liberal thinkers
but this soul body distinction is the
nearest thing to a coherent argument
that the transgender activists can
muster
sure my body might be male but my soul
and therefore my true self
is female
now we might be getting somewhere
but we are leaving the realm of biology
we are leaving the realm of the natural
sciences we are now entering into the
realm
of theology
most transgender activists refuse to do
this because they don't take theology
very seriously they think that theology
is just a bunch of make-believe they
think that it's a bunch of
unfalsifiable fantasies totally divorced
from the intellectual rigor of science
with a capital s
it is ironic of course that people who
believe that men can become women would
accuse anybody else of magical thinking
but there it is
[Music]
they do so because they don't understand
theology which is faith seeking
understanding
theology actually is the opposite of
make-believe and fantasizing just as
natural science is the rigorous
contemplation of the physical world so
too theology is the rigorous and logical
contemplation of faith and the
metaphysical world
transgenderism i want to make the
strongest case i possibly can for
transgenderism transgenderism in its
most coherent form not saying much but
this is the most coherent form you can
get
is a fundamentally religious movement
that makes three claims about the
relationship of the body to the soul
one that the body and the soul are
entirely separate and therefore can be
in conflict with one another
two that our true identity our authentic
self
is our soul it has nothing to do with
our bodies it has everything to do with
our souls and three
when our bodies and our souls are in
conflict we must reject our bodies and
we must entirely embrace
our souls
even to the point of mutilating our
bodies to better accord with our soul
those are the three
best points i can give you for
transgenderism
they're not new
this it seems like a new idea but it's
actually not a new idea understood in
this way transgenderism is nothing more
than an ancient heresy known as gnostic
dualism
gnostic dualism has held that the
physical world is an evil facade that
must be rejected for the pure and secret
world beyond matter
this heresy has gone by lots of names
over the centuries gnosticism
manichaeism in the third century
albigensianism in the 12th century it
keeps cropping up there are different
variations but it's always the same tune
like transgenderism all of these
heresies were not primarily popular with
the common people
all of these heresies throughout all of
history were of course popular with the
intellectuals only an intellectual could
be so stupid as to believe these
heresies i was reminded of this the
other day when judge katanji jackson was
in her confirmation hearings for the
supreme court she was asked a question
by marsha blackburn on this topic
senator blackburn said what is a woman
can you define what a woman is
and katanji jack judge jackson a federal
judge laughed she said of course i can't
i'm not a biologist i can't tell you
what a woman is
katanji jackson has two degrees from
harvard
only someone with two degrees from
harvard could be so stupid as to not
know what a woman is
like transgenderism all of these
heresies preached salvation through the
attainment of secret knowledge
in our secular age we would probably
prefer the word liberation to salvation
substantially it means the same thing
the only way that we can free ourselves
from the prison of the body according to
this view man trapped inside a woman's
body all that sort of language is
through the secret knowledge
hidden by the evil physical world
but this gnostic account of the soul is
simply not true
that's not the way the soul and the body
works the soul is not in fact separate
entirely distinct from the body the body
is not in fact a prison for the soul the
soul is the form of the body the soul is
the animating principle of life this is
not a typical way that we talk about
transgenderism because we've completely
thrown theology out the window but
transgenderism can only even possibly be
sort of understood as a theological
movement
hence are our necessity to apply the
rigors of theology to this movement and
it crumbles when you do that
it's sort of ironic that transgender
activists celebrate a day called the
trans day of visibility when the entire
premise of transgenderism is that we
must reject the visible world for the
secret invisible world everything that
is visible that's evil that's a lie our
bodies are a lie only the invisible is
what we must celebrate
now
the purpose of that lengthy biological
and theological digression
is to make crystal clear my central
point in tonight's
lecture that transgenderism is
completely wrong
completely wrong from the standpoint of
biology from the standpoint of
psychology from the standpoint of
theology and everywhere in between it is
entirely incoherent it doesn't make any
sense at all
the toleration of transgender ideology
benefits no one and harms everyone who
has the misfortune of encountering it
our society should reject transgenderism
entirely
which we have by the way we have for
most of american history
we did reject this entirely
despite the misguided efforts of some
transgender activists
transgenderism remains classified as a
mental illness in the diagnostic and
statistical manual for well over a
century until left-wing courts got a
little little activist cross-dressing
was illegal throughout much of the
united states including in san francisco
my how times have changed
i think today it is illegal not to cross
stress in san francisco
used to be the opposite
if a man thought that he was a woman for
most of our nation's history he would
receive counseling just as he does today
not just as he does today because in
those olden days until about five
minutes ago
the counseling would involve
presenting the man with reality and
trying to bring his delusions into
better accord with reality it would
consist in convincing him that he is in
fact a man
today
counseling which is called
gender affirming counseling how ironic
that you're convincing someone they are
the opposite sex you call that affirming
today it is all about affirming
delusion which helps no one and only
makes the problem worse
conservatives have been too soft on this
because we want to be nice because
we want to be open-minded generally
speaking we do not want to impose our
desires on other people we don't really
care that much we want to live and let
live i just want to have a good life and
not have these wackos try to trans my
kids in kindergarten that's what we want
and so we try to find a middle ground to
varying degrees conservatives have
tolerated transgender ideology
often you will hear conservatives use
phrases such as
biological male you've probably heard
that phrase
this would refer to men who think that
they're women but they're really men
in part by the way the the reason
conservatives use this phrase is because
the oligarchs who control our media and
our big tech platforms threaten to
completely silence us and throw us out
of the public square and shut down every
conservative outlet if we don't in some
way bend the knee to transgenderism so i
do understand from a tactical
perspective why some conservatives in
media and in politics use that phrase
the biological male is ultimately a
losing strategy
it does not oppose transgenderism it
does exactly the opposite when you use
the phrase biological male you are
implying that you can be some other kind
of male
you can be a biological male but a
spiritual female you are you are
implying that there is a distinction you
are accepting the entire premise
of transgenderism you're conceding the
whole point
conservatives will say things like
listen transgenderism it's fine for
adults
if a man wants to put on a dress and
call himself sally well doggone it
that's his right
that's none of my business he does the
right to do that
but he shouldn't impose it on kids
that's where we draw the line
or conservatives will say
if a man wants to live his life as a
woman that's completely fine but he
shouldn't be allowed to compete against
girls in sports
that would be unfair
yes of course that's unfair
everyone
did you see this photo a couple of weeks
ago of that hulking male swimmer wearing
the borat suit wearing a woman's
jumpsuit as a man standing next to women
and beating them and taking away their
trophies and taking away their glory
dwarfing the actual women on the ncaa
podium
of course that's unfair
but i hate i hate to say this i don't
want to sound insensitive
who cares i don't i don't very few
people care about women's sports yes we
support our sisters yes we support our
daughters nobody watches the wnba it's
not an actual concern
nobody cares
we we only pretend to care now
because it's the most socially
acceptable way to criticize
transgenderism so now all of a sudden
you're going to have conservatives
buying wnba subscriptions
it's ridiculous
the problem with transgenderism
is not that it complicates college swim
meets the problem is that it is a false
account of human nature that encourages
delusion and psychosis and
self-mutilation that's our issue folks
we just don't want to say it in one of
the stupidest supreme court decisions in
the history of our country
the uh the sometime romantic poet
justice anthony kennedy
asserted that
at the heart of liberty is the right to
define one's own concept of existence
of meaning
of the universe and of the mystery of
human life
wow man
i don't know where in the constitution
justice kennedy found that
uh unclear justice scalia mocked that as
the sweet mystery of life passage
or jurisprudence regardless of where
kennedy found it the the bottom of what
bong kennedy founded him regardless of
that it's it's just not true
no one has the right or the ability for
that matter
to define existence
their own reality on the contrary on the
contrary we have a responsibility to
accept reality
no one has the right even to engage in
whatever sort of private behaviors
tickle their fancy
you're not allowed to do certain drugs
maybe you want to but you're not we have
rules against that you're not allowed to
sell your organs i think that's a pretty
good rule it inhibits your individualism
i guess but i think it's a good law
you you are not allowed or at least you
were not allowed until very recently to
have doctors chop off your perfectly
healthy organs
you do not have any natural or
constitutional right to delusional and
destructive behavior
either the transgender vision that men
can secretly be women or vice versa
is correct
or it isn't
obviously it isn't
so why are we restructuring our law and
our politics and our culture according
to a premise that every sensible person
on planet earth knows is false
we cannot split the baby
the supposed right of confused people to
pretend to be the opposite sex
necessarily infringes on the rest of our
rights to distinguish between men and
women
because we live in a society
this is why we have fights over bathroom
bills and pronoun rules and the 2022
ncaa championship
and on and on and on
the only way to stop this transgender
madness is to oppose it entirely
there is no natural or constitutional or
civil right to fantasy
and there is nothing compassionate about
encouraging disturbed people to indulge
their destructive delusions
yes it's unfair that transgender
ideology permitted william leah thomas
to take the trophy away from the young
woman at the swim meet
but it's unfair because it's unjust and
it's unjust because it's based on lies
if you recognize
as we all do
as even i think most of the radical
leftists do when they're being really
honest with themselves if you recognize
that there is something wrong with the
picture of a giant man standing taking a
woman's trophy away while he stands
there in a woman's swimsuit if you
realize that there's something maybe
wrong
with that same giant man getting
undressed in the women's locker room
when they're asking him not to if you
realize
that transgender ideology doesn't make
any sense by any standard or vantage
whatsoever
then stop pussyfooting around the issue
the only way to stop this madness is to
stop tolerating the transgender ideology
entirely in all times in all places for
all people for the good of everyone full
stop thank you very much
thank you very much
now i believe ladies and gentlemen we
will now begin the q a session we ask
that you if you have a question you
carefully and quickly make your way over
to our associates and they will line you
up we ask that you remain respectful and
allow mr knowles to answer your question
you are allowed one question and one
question only and we also ask that you
have your question ready when you come
up to the front of the line thank you
we have a rule at the daily wire which i
vehemently disagree with
but we have this rule anyway that if you
disagree with me you can come to the
front of the line i think that if you
disagree with me you should be cast into
outer darkness where there is wailing
and gnashing of teeth but look rules are
rules so if you disagree with me feel
free to skip the line
hi mr knowles my name is andrew brown
and i'm a student here at the law school
my question for you is you spoke earlier
about theology and standing firm on
truth in regards to transgenderism
how can conservatives who are also
people of faith speak truth into
people's lives while also
loving them in a way that christ has
shown us well i i think the way to love
people is to speak the truth in love
right and both parts of that are very
important what what the left has said
especially on this issue of
transgenderism is that the truth is
cruel the truth that the man who thinks
he's a woman is a man that's cruel and
that that's awful and the only way to
set him free is to lie
now you might remember that a certain
fellow about two thousand years ago had
something to say about this issue and
said no it's not that
it's not that the truth is cruel and
lies will set you free it's that the
truth will set you free and that we have
to throw lies away all the time have no
no quarter for that so i i fear that
right now
a misbegotten compassion a misguided
compassion has conservatives really
disrespecting people when you when you
respect someone you tell them the truth
when when you respect someone you say
listen buddy put away the dress it's
you're not you're not a woman and people
are mocking you behind your back and
maybe maybe i'm not mocking you but
other people are and you look ridiculous
and it's for your own good that i'm
telling you this and that can be tough
but
sometimes love is tough there's a great
tapestry the bio tapestry
one of the more famous pieces of western
art and on it there is an image of a man
holding a club
smacking people with a club and it says
in latin here bishop odo holding a club
comforts the boys
doesn't seem very comforting does it
these are his own men by the way uh
bishop odo couldn't carry a sword into
battle he's a bishop there were
standards and so he carried a club and
when his cowardly men tried to retreat
he would smack him with the club and say
get back into battle
that's the real meaning of comfort isn't
it to give strength to somebody and so
that's what we ought to do and the
the weak and destructive voices who tell
us that uh the truth is evil that the
truth is harmful well those voices have
always been around and they're not on
the right side of things
hi michael my name is caleb i just was
wondering if you would co-write a sequel
to your best book with me so i can get
some royalty money
more reasons to vote for democrats
well i hate to disappoint you but i i
already have a in the works the 25th
anniversary edition it will be revised
and expanded
i guess not really revised i think it'll
be pretty much all the same thesis but
there are lots of books that we can work
on together you can do a carrot-esque
biography of the hillary clinton
presidency that would be a good one
you could uh you know write about the um
the devout catholicism of joe biden that
could be an interesting one
a lot of options
have your people call my people and
we'll set it up
i'm quinn hughes i'm a law student in
washburn um you referred to studies of
brain scans and individuals experience
experiencing gender dysphoria as dubious
could you elaborate on what specifically
makes these studies unreliable
sure i don't have the studies in front
of me i think all statistics are crap
i'm happy to cite them when they back up
my point but i don't have a great deal
of respect for them uh this is a new
phenomenon uh they are not particularly
well established they're i i know as
much to know that there is a great deal
of debate in the cognitive science
community about the realities of it but
actually the
reality of the brain stands is sort of
second to my point because my point is
merely to
discern exactly which sort of argument
the transgender activists are making and
the very fact that the goal posts
constantly are shifting i think speaks
to the validity of my thesis
the the at the center of transgenderism
is this issue of the sex gender
distinction
so if the sex is physical and the gender
is metaphysical then we can probe that
with theology if the sex is physical and
the the gender is physical as well then
we can probe that with biology but then
it would be meaningless to say that the
man is a man or the man is a woman the
man would have to be some sort of third
category so now you're not talking about
transgenderism you're talking about
something more akin to hermaphroditism
or intersexuality which the experts and
again the last two years i've grown a
little tired of the experts and a little
suspect of them but but even so the
experts seem to suggest that
intersexuality the physical condition of
sexual ambiguity is a really really
really rare condition much much rarer
than transgenderism which is now
exploding as a social phenomenon so i
suppose the cognitive scientists could
come back and rewrite their thesis on
intersexuality and hermaphroditism sure
and then we could take a look at it then
but but until then regardless of what
any of these studies show the point that
they're making remains incoherent and so
i'm just waiting for one
unified thesis and then i look forward
to knocking that one down too
thank you
hi my name is ian zwink i'm a student at
washburn law uh you've interviewed
michael malus and so i'm curious to hear
some of your thoughts on the benefits of
either national divorce or his idea of
anarchy anarchy where we essentially
dissolve the government and privatize
everything
i was young once i was a kid once i had
all sorts of ideas i love michael malus
he's a very sharp guy and he's extremely
funny so i i love having him on the show
but
we have basically as separate political
views as as divergent political views as
two people sort of on the right could
possibly have i just don't buy it i
think national divorce is wrong-headed
first of all people are forgetting that
national divorces are not peaceful maybe
in some utopian novel by iran they are
but in reality they're not they look
like partition in india they look like
civil war throughout eastern europe or
the middle east they look like civil
civil war in the united states for that
matter and so it doesn't happen you
don't you don't really see
in practice peaceful national divorces
so before we speak flippantly about it i
think we need to be at the point where
we're ready to shoot our cousins in the
face i myself am not but moreover i find
it sort of weak i don't want to give the
libs southern california i don't want
them to give i don't want to give them
new york for that matter either i don't
think they have any right to it i don't
think they have any right to for
instance in their states vote for
abortion i don't think they have any
right at all i want to go in and conquer
those places and i want to have my
country back i don't want to give them
half of my country and some of the best
geographies so i think we ought to fight
and take it back and wield the political
power that the people give us on the
happy occasions that they do and by the
way i don't think we would have to
conquer new york or california even for
that matter i think people tend to be a
lot more sensible than the ruling class
has been in the last 20 or 30 years so i
don't like that in terms of anarchism no
i'm a conservative my friend i i reject
all sorts of these modern ideologies
anarchism uh communism socialism this
isn't that ism
i don't like the isms i'm i am a man i'm
not i don't want to be an ist or
anything like that i just want to be a
gentleman and have a good country and so
i i think that it would be much wiser
not to fall into the traps of the left
and think that we can recreate society
out of our unfettered reason in a way
that's never been tried including in
iceland the anarchists always try to say
that iceland was some anarchist utopia
in the 9th century or something and it's
total crap and even if it were true it
hasn't happened in a very long time so i
don't want to do that i don't want to
throw away my cultural patrimony i just
want to have a good society and i think
it would be a lot easier to pull from
the best of our traditions and to
exercise prudence which is a virtue than
it would be to remake society anew
whitaker chambers the ex-communist who
became a conservative he made this point
in
witness
he said that
communism is not the newest ideology
it's the second oldest it goes back to
the garden of eden when the serpent told
eve ye shall be his gods uh this idea
took hold during the modern era
especially in the enlightenment and it
was a left-wing idea and and then
conservatives seem to grab hold of it in
some ways too on some of the isms that
they hold dear but it's always silly our
unfettered reason ain't going to do it
we're not that smart so i i think we
ought to
look back toward that great democracy
the democracy of the dead look back to
the wisdom of our fathers and and help
to restore and defend and rebuild the
the civilization that we've been given
hi michael my name is jessica mkhitaryan
i graduated washburn a few years ago
so
recently in the last couple years we've
seen conservative take
more moderate liberals under their wing
and say see we're not so different
this has come up again in the news
recently with fox news hiring bruce
jenner who now calls himself caitlyn and
i was wondering what are your thoughts
on this tendency of conservatives lately
i would never criticize fox news
i wouldn't i would never do that
it certainly raised my eyebrow when i
saw that when i saw that news
and the statement made by the ceo was
was that caitlyn
she is a crusading pioneer in the lgbt
plus community
and this is why it's so important to
have
transgenderism represented on the news
or something
on the one hand it's actually proving
right what fox has said for a long time
fox has said it's fair and balanced
and and the left has always mocked that
and said no fox is a far right
conservative news channel
no i think fox is pretty moderate
actually
fox's hiring has hired lots and lots of
democrats and now is is
presenting transgenderism as though that
were some sort of normal or
normal ideology and something perhaps
even to be embraced so uh
it's not particularly conservative
that's for sure but it gets to a
tendency that a lot of republicans and
conservatives have fallen into
which is
we just want to please everybody
because we're nice it's actually i don't
even think it's cynical i'm really not
questioning the motives of even a big
corporation like fox and i'm not
certainly not questioning the motives of
conservatives we want to be nice and we
want to be liked and we don't want to
tell people no and we want to let them
do whatever they want to do and so
there then comes this political
advantage that they think is an
advantage where they'll say haha
we're pushing transgenderism now on our
airways see the democrats are the real
transphobes
you say
no no we are we actually are i mean
we're not it's not phobic we're not
irrationally afraid of anything or
anyone we just reject the ideology and
the party that welcomes every single
idea doesn't stand for a damn thing at
all and that that's certainly true of
the republican party and the
establishment on the right so
so that that was very disappointing to
see that that uh turn and and
sometimes you will hear this
even beyond the
good hearted efforts the good hearted
motivations or the cynical motivations
you'll hear the apathetic response oh
who cares
who cares what's the big deal
well sure bruce jenner is
the one of the greatest athletes in
recent history and he's obviously he's
the guy on the wheaties box and we just
know he's a man but who cares if he's
now calling himself caitlyn and uses the
female pronouns who cares
the left cares
the left seems to care a whole lot and
they're investing a ton of money and
energy and time and focus and resources
into getting us all to pretend that a
man is secretly a woman and vice versa
why because it matters a whole lot
because language color is the way that
we view the world if bruce jenner is
really caitlyn then she has every right
to go use the ladies bathroom she's a
she after all her name is caitlin and
that's a girl's name
if bruce jenner
who i'm told is a very nice guy i don't
know him personally he was always sort
of republican
if bruce jenner is not actually caitlin
is not really she is a man and we call
him he
that paints a very different picture and
we see instantly
of course the man has no right to use
the woman's bathroom
the left always manipulates language to
set the stage for their cultural
revolution
that's what political correctness is
that's what wokeness is that's what
cancer culture is it's all getting to
this language issue the debates over
free speech
the fact that a public university
president was condemning me for speaking
at a university and saying men are not
women i mean that's that's the kind of
focus that we're talking about and
they're doing it because it's given them
they're they are doing it because it's
given them the whole culture it's very
effective and i think we need to draw
lines too and say no
i'm not because of some misguided desire
to be nice i'm not going to call the man
and address
she it's not good for him it's certainly
not good for us and it's just not true
and you're not going to make me lie
hey michael my name is francisco
and i had a question on
you mentioned how transgenderism
is kind of an old heresy
gnostic dualism
and how it was usually found only in the
intellectual circles
i wanted to know what you thought maybe
we're in this new generation the zoomers
20 of them
are in this camp
um why is that
there was a video that came out the
other day of the corporate president of
the walt disney company
and she was describing how we need to
have lots more lgbt lmnop the list goes
on and on characters as leads in the
shows and she said this was a personal
issue for her because she has
one transgender child and one pan gender
or pansexual child
which is statistically impossible that
can't happen we're talking about an
affliction that historically
concerns what point zero zero one
percent of the population and
pansexuality has existed for two seconds
i mean it doesn't really exist but even
as a concept it's existed for about two
seconds it's not possible that that is
the case what has really happened is a
social phenomenon has spread in
extraordinarily elite circles in
particular such as the circles in which
a corporate president of disney might
run and i don't have a statistic on this
but i told you i don't really believe in
statistics
in my experience
transgenderism sexual confusion
is far far more pronounced among the
wealthy among the influential among the
coastal circles than it is in the middle
ordinary
blue collar parts of the country
only an intellectual could be so stupid
i mean this this does get right back to
the gospel since you mentioned the
gnostic heresy
in the gospels
how many times are the geniuses the
intellectuals the professors
how many times are these types of
characters
mocked and derided
we're told that to to enter the kingdom
of heaven you have to be like a child
not childish but childlike
you have to it reminds me of the the iq
bell curve meme have you seen this is
one of my favorite memes where it's the
iq bell curve and down at the bottom
with the big drooling idiot he says the
men men are not women or something to
that effect and then you get to the
genius who has i don't know an iq of 120
and he says no actually no men can be
women because sex and gender is
different and because this sociologist
told me so when i was a sophomore at
princeton and therefore whatever and
then you get up to the true genius
mathematician monk jedi and he says
no actually men are not women actually
that's just the way it is the stupid guy
was right and i i think that's that's
what we're seeing now
the disney leaks that christopher ruther
put out the other day drew at home for
me sixty percent of americans support
the parental rights and education bill
in florida
100
of the elites in this country oppose
that bill at the corporate level
at the governmental level at the media
level at the technology level
why the disparity
uh it's happened throughout history it
happens again and again and again
and it's incumbent upon us we the people
who still ostensibly have the right to
rule ourselves to tamp down those
experts if the last two years haven't
shown you that the experts are
completely incompetent and usually
corrupt idiots i don't know how to help
you i you know you've seen it you've
seen it with your own eyes and so it
seems to me the logical next step is we
the people people of the united states
who are so dumb that we know that men
are not women we need to exercise that
power and rein in our elites who have
become out of control
i'm jada i go here
so
one thing that i've heard of that i
i've not heard any conservative or
liberal people saying
is that while there's a
increase in
like transgender woman to men that's
going on there's also an increase in
women being diagnosed with autism in
their teens and twenties i don't know if
you've heard anything about that or
about any studies that might relate
having gender dysphoria with autism and
maybe if it's a symptom of that nobody's
talking about
i have i was reading one of these today
actually that uh a young gal i forget
her name
uh
was uncomfortable in her body as all as
all teenagers are
it happened to you as well well could
you tell
before i tell you about some article i
read on the internet what happened i was
told to keep it brief but i guess i'll
tell you oh yeah yes
keep it long keep it lengthy i want to
hear the story
as a kid i
i didn't
i i liked both girl and boy things as a
kid which that's what a lot of people go
through and then as soon as i hit
puberty it's like
i could not deal with the changes in my
body
and i didn't really have a word for it
yet as transgenderism but like
i would bind my chest in secret i would
make my clothes to where like it would
hide my hips
and
you know i had my church and my family
who was like
they reaffirmed me that i was a girl
which i'm very thankful for because at
that point i definitely wanted to go on
hormones as soon as i could and if i was
still it with the influence of the
left and the lgbt
like
i would have gone on hormones and i
would have de-transitioned because it
was a symptom of my autism that i got
diagnosed with at 20 and it wasn't like
actual gender dysphoria
i've heard a number of stories i told
you i was reading one of these today
abigail schreier has written a book
about it called irreversible damage
about the regret about these same sorts
of issues that you're talking about
which is good and the media completely
shut it out you are not allowed to tell
that story the young woman i spoke to
just the other day helena kirschner she
is not allowed to tell her story about
coming to realize no i'm not i'm not
actually a man i realize this isn't
working you were so fortunate you were
so fortunate
that your family and your community
were saying
you were so fortunate that your family
and community were sane and did not
indulge this delusion and the scariest
part the scariest part is that a lot of
the families who will indulge
this kind of transgender mania that
could be caused by any other number of
conditions notably autism though you're
right that is cropping up quite a lot
a lot of these families just want to do
what's best for their kid and they're
being told by these sickos on television
and in the universities and in the
political apparatus that the only way to
treat your kid is to lop off their
genitals and inject them with cross-sex
hormones absolute irreversible damage
that would have caused frankly and as
you're describing in your case greater
regret than when you were
and stress and anxiety than you were
experiencing even in the moment that's
incredibly i'm so glad that you were
able to come through that and have a
real medical diagnosis in the end that
did not result in you
mutilating yourself
it's amazing
shout out to my mom in my catholic
church i'm sorry i say one more time
shout out to my mom in my catholic
church yeah good job good job mom good
job church and really great stuff thank
you thank you for telling that story
wow
wow
hi michael i'm deanne um question for
you i know you probably haven't noticed
coming into kansas city that we have a
lot of crazy stuff coming
occurring in our country and then
especially kansas
so i was wondering other than the
mailbag is there an email um contact
that we can send like newsworthy
articles or tips to please do there is a
daily wire tip line
i you know i'm because i'm not a
reporter i don't deal usually with the
tip lines but i have a personal website
where you can go and submit things my uh
i won't call them fans on the left
occasionally will send love letters to
me through that it's always a pleasure
uh but but i'm always interested in
hearing these stories because
it in the olden days of even just a few
years ago
when you're putting a show together of
commentary you read the news and that's
how you're supposed to find the news
today the most important news most
interesting news that's going on is the
stuff that's not being reported it's the
stuff that's being kept out of the
papers and the websites and tv shows so
i'm always happy to hear that and i
think most important stories that we're
getting i give an example luke rosiak at
daley wire broke a story about a rape
that occurred because of transgender
policies in a restroom in loudoun county
and that was then covered up by the
administrators the student was sent to
another school happened again
that story which no one was going to
cover daily wire broke it
that story may have
changed the gubernatorial election in
virginia it's a very important story
it's important to the safety of students
it's important to the political
direction of the state of the country
the commonwealth of the country so yeah
please send in those tips you can find
it on my personal website
thanks
it's time for our final question of the
final question it's terrible okay
hi michael my name's alex um i'm a local
mom here in the area
and so
you know being is how i have children i
i worry about the state of
i mean i homeschool but i see what's
going on because i love my children
but
just kidding
but
they're not kidding
they're not getting at all
but i see what's going on in the school
systems you know and i don't understand
i know that these people know a lot of
them they know
that men are men and women are women
and i don't understand the motivation or
the agenda
why are they trying to push it on to
young children what is the motivation
there that they're trying what are they
trying to accomplish with us the
motivation is to create a generation of
revolutionaries that's the motivation i
actually don't think that their
motivation is some kind of pedophilic
interest in kids hopefully not at least
for most of them i think the interest is
that
sex is one of the most powerful forces
in human nature and if you can control
it then you can much more easily mold
people and that's especially true when
our brains are nice and squishy in the
earliest days of our education and
education is not just reading writing
and arithmetic it's ethics it's how we
view the world it's how we understand
the nature between body and soul and
everything else so that that's one part
of it the other part of it is this
attempt to redefine reality going back
to the garden of eden when the serpent
tells eve ye shall be his gods
this is a lion by the way i'm not just
pulling that out of thin air
john kennedy
in a speech in 1963 i believe it was
quoted george bernard shaw the socialist
playwright and he said shaw pointed out
some people see things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say why not and he he uttered this line
as they were supposed to be inspiring
and a lot of democrat politicians have
used it since
what he doesn't point out is that that
line comes from a play by george bernard
shaw a place cycle called back to
methuselah it's in the character of the
serpent tempting eve in the garden of
eden
as satan very famously said this
inspiring line from bielsa bob the devil
himself i
and so he he uses this line but that
really is the agenda right it's to re
remake society we the past is always
terrible according to the progressives
the past was awful we never want to go
back there and then the presence always
a crisis and the future is going to be
really really great just give us more
power just give us more of your rights
and and abolish more of your customs
that's what they tell you
never quite works out that way but that
has been the project and so
changing society in terms of its tax
rates okay
changing the health care system it's a
pretty big deal but you know whatever
changing the way our energy sector works
as the environmentalists are trying to
do with the green new deal for instance
sure that's a big deal
but if you can redefine
human nature if you can actually get
everyone to believe or if not believe at
least say that a man is a woman and a
woman is a man
you can redefine anything and and i
think that's what's really at the heart
of this transgender obsession the libs
accuse us of being obsessed
with sex
we were just minding our own business
having kids and being normal people with
our families it's the libs who who are
the aggressors in the sexual revolution
it's the libs who decided that men are
not women
and men can become women and vice versa
it's the libs who are trying to trans
the kids in freaking kindergarten for
goodness sakes don't call me the
aggressor
they are the ones doing it they are
obsessed with it and they're obsessed
with it because politically it's
extraordinarily powerful and it's why
every single conservative
sometimes we're asked is this the hill
you want to die on yes if you don't die
on a hill if you're not willing to at
least stand up to die on a hill you're
going to run out of hills there's not
going to be a battle anymore stand up
this is
the issue
thank you very much thank you to
everyone it's really been a pleasure to
be with you tonight thank you so much i
look forward to seeing you the next time
i'm in topeka kansas thank you
thank
you again